bonsoir kim ngu remercie d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france donc ce
retrait officiel aujourd'hui de la
turquie c'est quoi c'est une provocation
en plein forum génération égalité oui
c'est une provocation le message à une
charge symbolique importante
il s'agit de contenter et de rassurer la
frange la plus radicale la plus
conservatrice de l'électorat des douanes
pour lui il n'est plus question
d'essayer de convaincre les libéraux
l'opposition rats socialistes social
démocrate centriste du pays
pour lui il s'agit d' opposant un qu'il
faut isoler qu'il faut montrer du doigt
et il faut voir cette décision de
retrait de la turquie de la convention
d'istanbul comme une volonté non
seulement de de défier le monde
occidental les démocraties mais
également de défier la société civile
turque l'opposition turque
la femme turque et permettre en quelque
sorte à ce que l'extrême droite qui le
soutient soit encore plus visible et
soient encore plus offensive sur l'arène
politique turque
vous venez de décrire des motivations
des considérations à l'intérieur de la
turquie nationale donc il ya aussi une
sacrée distance qui est prise avec
l'europe
oui mais croyez moi d'abord c'est c'est
la volonté et d'attaquer l'opposition et
de montrer sa toute puissance
la face à une opposition qui reste
extrêmement importantes notamment dans
les métropoles
là où effectivement la société civile se
mobilise et dénonce les pratiques les
dérives du régime autoritaire et donc en
fait le message est surtout lancé à
l'arrière-pays au la population la plus
conservatrice et là on le voit
clairement revenir à ses fondamentaux
les plus réactionnaires d'abord c'est de
nouveau faire appel à référencer ses
l'islamiste faire par exemple faire en
sorte que la femme soit reléguée à son
rôle de deux individus qui ne l'est que
pour procréer et à son rôle de maternité
et deuxièmement c'est aussi lancé un
message vis-à-vis de l'extrême droite
est montré en fait que la femme
finalement c'est une marchandise et que
l'homme a une toute puissance sur la fin
donc on a là une volonté véritablement
de tourner la turquie 1 vers les 1 16
heures les plus sombres et faire en
sorte que les démocrates turcs eux se
sentent étrangers dans leur propre pays
effectivement on a du mal à se sauver
encore il ya quelques années il ya 15
ans la turquie a frappé aux portes de
l'europe
qu'en pense que les turcs on voit
envoyés sur ces images ces
manifestations l'opinion publique peut
être se retourner contre eux erdogan sur
ce type de sujet très certainement alors
vous savez la turquie c'est un pays
particulier parce que on a un film et
féminisme d'état qui est née avec la
proclamation de la république de turquie
c'est quand même un pays qui a été
pionnier dans le respect des droits des
femmes le droit de vote des femmes et 10
depuis 1934
donc c'est un pays qui avait une
certaine avance sur la france ou la
belgique où d'autres pays occidentaux
c'est un pays où l'égalité hommes femmes
est plus ou moins garanti par les
gouvernements a été garanti par les
gouvernements successifs où il existe
une société civile extrêmement dynamique
extrêmement puissante et donc on ne voit
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui même à l'instant
même que des femmes se mobilisent mais
des hommes aussi des hommes féministes
se mobilise également des gens qui a
paradoxalement sont plutôt conservateurs
mais craignent pour la vie des femmes
nature qui est devenu un véritable
charnier pour femmes on en compte plus
de 300 morts identifiés pour l'année
dernière cent soixante et onze femmes
assassinées dans des circonstances
troubles cette année on observe la même
tendance
alors la convention
d'istanbul ne protège pas complètement
les femmes des violences
ah mais il s'agit d'un dispositif de
dissuasion et c'est important les
symboles sont très importants
aujourd'hui si on veut défendre les
femmes
il faut défendre la convention
d'istanbul c'est le message que veulent
donner en ce moment même les
manifestantes et les manifestants turcs
pourtant on l'a entendu après derrière
dahmane s'en défend et il a clairement
dit on n'a pas attendu ce texte là pour
notre lutte contre la violence faite aux
femmes et on n'attendra pas non plus la
presle et des justes quand même c'est un
combat qu'il mène
c'est de la commune ce discours tous ces
discours qui touchent les femmes sont
des violences faites aux femmes
quand il déclare en 2016 que la fin doit
être relégué à son rôle de procréation
que elle doit enfanter est assurée ce
faire les gars rentrent finalement de la
société de la famille traditionnelle
turque
c'est une violence quand il aime il
harangue les familles y compris celles
de l'opposition à qui les traitent comme
des des individus ddd femme délurée etc
il fait violence aux femmes donc il
reste dans un registre et on le voit on
voit cette tendance depuis plusieurs
années déjà
ils s'attaquent régulièrement aux femmes
et à leurs droits et donc ce qu'il vient
de décider le retrait de la turquie donc
de la convention d'istanbul est dans la
continuité de cette volonté de renouer
avec le conservatisme le plus virulent
et éloigner la turquie des standards
démocratiques élémentaires
merci beaucoup à barr qui mesure d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france